Hello everyone, I'm VOA's Rebecca Ward for Going Green.
Or, should I say, greens.
Freshly picked from the farm to the table...
...even in a metropolitan area like Washington.
According to the Department of Agriculture,...
...more than 12,000 farms in the United States are part of a CSA:...
...Community Supported Agriculture.
That's where a family or individual buys a share of the farm's produce.
Hiu Newcomb and her daughter Hana own Potomac Vegetable Farms just outside Washington.
The farmers' markets and the CSA combined...
...have really altered the landscape of how we get our money.
1980s were, I think, the first farmers' markets.
And our first CSA, it was in 2000.
So between 1980 and 2000, we're getting bigger and bigger.
But the CSA, it's really changed the way,...
...we're far more in control than we used to be.
Hard to believe that neither Hiu Newcomb nor her husband had any experience in farming...
...when they first got started 30 something years ago.
But we weren't farmers.
My husband did not come from a farming background, nor did I.
And I think he just had a thought that he would like to someday create a utopian community.